From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Today is Tuesday, September 22, 2011. My name is Joe Maniere of the Southern World History Program in the University of North Carolina.
I'm at Chapel Hill. I'm a videographer, John Bishop in Washington, DC at the Jefferson Building of the Library of Congress to record an old history of you for the Civil Rights History Project,
which is a joint undertaking of the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture and the Library of Congress.
We are really honored and privileged today to have with us Miss Doris and Ladner.
Dory.
And Dr. Joyce Ladner, sister's worship and Mississippi who have had.
Joyce Ann as well.
Long long history of involvement in progressive struggle and movement.
And let me know as well where to land and have a whiskey lane, Nichols, who is the project career at the museum.
And I think you're not one of the people who has to give you a drink or not work to have a glass of tea car.
Okay. Miss Ladner, Dr. Ladner, thank you so much for coming in and sitting down to the bridge and...
Thank you.
You've sent me the challenge of opening with a complicated or stimulating question.
I thought I might...
We can work back for this.
But let me take you back since we're sitting here on the mall in Washington DC.
Let me take you back to it.
I might have seen some decree.
And I want to ask about the March, but most particularly, I want to ask about the ambivalence in the range of thought and feeling criticism that you had about that experience,
because I know it was a complicated question.
Well, my feelings were one of ambivalence and complicated in that there were so many things going on in the front line,
meaning that Medgevus had been killed on June 12th.
This funeral was June 16th.
And Lars Giyat had been beaten, Miss Fannie Lou Hamer had been jailed and beaten very badly in Wai'anone, Mississippi.
And there was a bus boycott going...
Not a bus boycott, but a boycott of all the stores in Jackson, Mississippi.
And people were being arrested in Greenwood, Mississippi.
We were under siege.
So we knew that we had to return back to these homes.
We had three guys on death row in Georgia.
So coming together was good to address...
Bring out grievances to the seat of government to let the president and everybody know.
But we knew that we had to return back to those towns and what would be waiting for us.
I really looked forward to coming here and to letting everybody know what was going on.
But in reality, James Farmer, who was the executive director of Corps, was in jail in Placman, Paris, Louisiana, he couldn't attend.
So my sister, Joace, worked in the Marchion Washington office coordinating the transportation to working out the logistics.
And I was working in the SNCC office raising money for the organization's lablihood and also recruiting people to participate in the same march.
But the point was I was always thinking about what was going on because I'm a frontline person and always thinking about the strategy.
And my sister was talking about the fun we had and I was thinking about the other side of it.
And I said, one to say that death shall have no dominion over what we were doing at the same time because we didn't fear death as well as enjoying ourselves partying and so forth.
We were young and zealots.
We were zealots.
So in essence, the one thing that bothered us was that we didn't see, which always kept us going and when they wanted to change John's speech.
But I'll let Joace talk about that because she was involved back there with Portland and Jim and so forth.
But that was one thing that turned us off.
And we were always busy.
We had all this energy.
Energy.
19, 20 years old, you're very energetic.
Very busy.
I was at a conference, student conference, and Lake Forest, Illinois, the day that MegaEvers was killed.
And I had gone there as a SNCC representative to try to recruit students and also to raise money and to spread generally spread the word about the Southern movement.
And I got a call while I was at this conference one evening from Rubidara's Robinson and Rubidys said,
Joace, MegaEvers has been killed.
And I said, oh my god, I've got to go home.
We've got to get back to Jackson.
And she said, no, you need to go to Washington to work on the Marchion Washington.
I said, yeah, but I've known MegaEvers since I was 14.
I mean, I was very upset.
I think I was even crying.
I'm sure I was.
And she said, but we need to send two representatives from SNCC to work on the March.
And I want you to go from there, from get you an airline ticket.
And I want you to go to New York City for the rest of the summer to work on the Marchion.
And she said, this is, I remember so clearly, this is what Meg would have expected of you.
I wanted you to do one of the others, she said.
And I was like, taking a bag, but I always had the ability to think with my head,
even in difficult emotional times.
So I saw the logic of what she could, and why could appeal to my logic,
so she appealed to that part of me.
And so I was then off to New York to work at the Harlem headquarters for Marchion Washington.
And I spent the summer there working under Biod Rustin's direction.
There were, we, Dorianna State with Rachelle Hart, who was a young person,
and she lived at, was 8th Avenue in 24th Street in the ILGW Condo Apartments.
And she had one bedroom apartment there.
Dorianna slept on the sofa, and then later in the summer, Ellen Holmes arrived.
And she was at Yale Law School, and she came, and she joined us up at the Marchion Quarters.
So Dorianna was working out at the SNCC office for Rachelle Eleanor,
and I worked up in the Harlem office at the March.
And my job really was to raise money.
So I went, I don't know, I went out, I went out to Jersey, around the city,
spreading the word about the March, and why it was so important to bring people
who were involved in the movement from the South to participate in the March.
So Rachelle used to say that every time Joyce went out to be a lawyer,
she went out to raise money, she came back with enough to run another bus.
And that was what was important to us.
We worked long hours, we worked on Saturday, it was very tiring.
One Saturday I remember seeing Malcolm X for the first time.
He used to speak on Coenah 125th Street, and stopped and listened to him speak.
And as I said, we worked very long hours, we did whatever Biot told us to do.
So it was well organized.
Very well organized, he was a great organizer, he had a very clear tactical sense.
And he saw the big picture and he, you know, anything he asked us to do, we did.
But he also left us with enough flexibility, you know, to be independent and go out there
and do what had to be done.
So every night, we worked late at night, came into back to the apartment.
And there was Bobbie Dylan sitting on the sofa, strumming his guitar,
and I wanted to go to sleep.
And he would sit there at the midnight, and I just couldn't wait until he got asleep.
He was sitting there, entertaining, enduring.
And, you know, he was well known, but we were all young people at the time.
I didn't see him as a great, you know, famous person, I think.
We were peers in a way.
And then we went down to Washington for the march, the day before.
And we stayed at what was then called the Statli-Hilton Hotel.
It's now 16 things, say.
Right, it's the Washington, not Washington, but the Hilton.
I'm not sure what the official name of that hotel is, but it was, back then it was called the Statli-Hilton.
And it was the March Hotel.
And I remember, there were a lot of media people, a lot of people who were there for the march.
And I remember meeting Malcolm X, seeing him rather in the lobby after the march.
And I'm pretty sure I saw him there before the march occurred as well.
No, we'd saw him the morning after we'd pick it to the Justice Department.
Yeah, early that morning we went down to pick it to the Justice Department.
Because of Don Harris, John Prado and John Prado.
We were in jail in America's Georgia.
And they were jailed for sedition.
Essentially what they were doing was trying to organize.
And that was the charge that were pledged charge.
That was the tremendous charge.
Because they could have been killed.
And we had petitioned the federal government to no avail.
So we picked it up about six o'clock that morning.
Then we got read it earlier, went on over to the mall for the march.
And I had a pass, a stage pass because that was on the staff.
And so what I remember first was seeing all those people.
It was an incredible sight.
19-year-old from Mississippi who had never seen huge numbers.
In fact, no one on that platform had seen numbers like that before.
But I remember seeing people of Mark coming and coming and coming.
And they just kept coming.
And then I saw the people on stage.
And I think I might have been impressed by some of them.
But I think probably most about Josephine Baker.
She was the person I remembered most.
And I mean, because she was a legend.
And I could not imagine that I would have ever met her.
Very grearious and exotic looking.
And she was shaking everyone's hand, hugging people and so on.
And then seeing the actors, people in movies up there.
And that was even though there were people who were very strong supporters of SNCC,
who raised a lot of money for us.
And then seeing the union guys on stage.
In seeing the Haley Ajax and then hearing her sing.
In other words, it was just kind of across the swath of a lot of people,
you know, who are the swath of America on that stage.
I remember seeing Marlon Brando.
And I used to, I felt, I got the kind of chills when I saw him and Josephine Baker.
And I was thinking more than anything else that I support really ran deep, you know.
That was what I felt.
And I saw Lena Horn.
And I met her earlier in the summer because she came to Jackson, Mississippi,
at the request of maybe it was before he was killed.
But we also, I met her at the Delta Sigma Theta Convention at summer in New York
when John Trump Power, who was later my roommate at Tuvalu,
and Joyce Barrett, who worked with SNCC in Southwest Georgia,
and I, we were all Delta's.
There were two white girls who were Delta members of Delta Sigma Theta.
And we were all in the movement.
So Jean Noble, who was the Delta Sigma Theta president at the time,
and was from Albany, Georgia, and Professor at the time at Brooklyn College.
Later at NYU, invited us to speak about what was happening in the South.
And the Delta's were very activist oriented.
And they used to bail other Delta's young Delta sorrows out of jail in the South.
And so we spoke about, at the convention, about what was happening.
And Lena Horne talked about having been down in Jackson.
And she had a very, very strong, deep emotional tie to the movement.
Very unusual.
She felt it in her soul.
Look, Lexus.
Her mother had, according to her biography, her mother had taken her to Georgia,
her natural mother, because she was reared by her grandmother, her father's mother,
had taken her to Georgia.
And she stayed for a long period of time.
And she so identified with that area, because she never lost her southern accent.
And Bill is straight horned, was also with her and her son.
And I remember being at a house there in Jackson with Dr. Noble president of Delta,
Lena Horne, Dick Gregory.
And I'm not sure who has made it.
Ebbers was there.
And they were all talking.
And here I'm like 2019 and 20 years old sitting there observing them.
And the one thing about Lena Horne was that when Joyce and I were on the platform
at the Lincoln Memorial, the French television wanted to interview her.
She said, no, these are the young people you should interview.
She said, she said, she's have to be interviewed.
And she took me by the hand and took me over to the, I think it was NBC,
that NASA Dickerson, the legendary female reporter, television news person,
was upon a scaffold and we climbed up the scaffold and she told her interview this young person,
because young woman, because she lives in the south and she knows what it's like.
So she was very generous in that regard.
And I remember being interviewed and when I got back home,
we later to this Hattiesburg, my mother said, I saw you on TV.
And that was like, so this is 1963.
You remember 50 years, almost 50 years ago.
And it was television wasn't what it is now.
So it was so strange.
And mother said, yeah, all the neighbors, she said, Ms. Katie saw you.
And Ms. Adder saw you.
She went on all the neighbors who had seen me as well.
And my younger sisters and brothers said as well.
And that made, my mother was a low-key, no nonsense, strong will,
very strong will and kind of shy, but she liked me.
Right, right, just the opposite of me.
And she would give you a lot of compliments, but when she gave you one,
she said, well, you look nice up there.
And I said, thank you, mother.
And that meant everything because, and she had had a lot of ambivalence
about our involvement in the movement because she was afraid that,
number one, something could happen to us.
And also she always worried that the house would be burned down by the clan.
But mother started off teaching us, let me go back to how we,
it all started when we were very young.
And then when we were talking with her telling us to always look white men
and eyes when you're talking to them, and don't blink, never look down.
And we were like four and five years old.
And she grew up in an integrated community in Wayne County, Mississippi.
And so she really should have checked the way she saw people.
And she would never fear anyone.
So she always told us to know we was good as anybody.
That was the mantra that passed through five generations of our family,
a maternal line of our family, and we can go back in a minute and talk about that.
But mother, she was, while she had ambivalence and some fear and
trepidation about our involvement, but always remember that she never told us not to go.
And that was important.
She never said, stay here, never.
So when I remember on that day, being interviewed by French media reporter
and then NASA Dickerson at NBC.
And so it was, but what I remembered most was John Lewis' speech.
Because I was on the podium with Cortland, Mildred and Jim Foreman.
And John, there were others around, but that small core group of people
was when John was saying, well, I don't want to change anything.
I don't want to.
And he wasn't screaming at the shouting because he's soft-poken.
And Jim was saying, well, they should be telling us what to do.
And of course, as words spread out in the crowd to the snake people,
everybody got very upset because this was our speech and what we felt most of all
was that this archbishop doesn't know what we go through.
Who is he, what right, an authority?
And we always challenged authority.
Who gave him the right to decide what John should say.
And it was a crisis on the platform for a while.
And finally, the language was changed as little as possible.
And he gave the speech.
But that was that and the guy, our friends being in jail in America's Georgia
were the defining things I remember most that I remembered now about the march.
Of course, I remember King's speech, but we had an ambivalent relationship with King as well.
We called, referred to him as the law, D-E-L-A-W-D, like the Lord.
And everybody's looking up to him when, in fact,
the snake people went into the most dangerous areas, like Albany and places.
And we called it breaking an area.
Staying there under the toughest conditions until you finally have a breakthrough
with a local community when they begin to let you stay with them.
Then you begin to, they come out to the meetings and they start getting involved in organizing as well.
And then it builds up to a crisis stage and that's when King would come in.
We felt.
And so we had an ambivalent relationship with him.
We respected him, of course.
But it wasn't all, oh, this is a fantastic man.
This is a great speechy gate.
Because that wasn't it.
The reality was that we knew we were leaving that next day.
I left the next morning with John Lewis on a flight back to Atlanta.
Funny which you remember, I remember the plane was in the back of the airline.
There was a round seating area, like a circular sofa back there.
And John and I were sitting back there.
And we went to the SNCC office and I went back there because I was waiting for a ride back
to Hattisburg because a week later I was going back to Tugeloo for my senior year.
How did you get back in a car?
But did you go back to New York first?
No, I went to Hattis to Jackson.
Well, John, I guess it was because I was given a plane ticket because I had been on the staff to get back south.
Otherwise I would have been in the car as well.
And then what I remember is that I don't remember riding a high euphoria either.
I'm not sure that I'm, of course, a time and events reshaped memory.
But I don't recall having seen that as something that I savored and carried with me.
Because we couldn't for long because we were right back in that same tough environment.
Three weeks later we got on the bus and Bob Moses drove a school bus to Birmingham.
And he took a dozen of more SNCC workers to the funeral of the three little girls who had been murdered.
So I always saw that as, okay, back in your face you had your big marks but we were back in control, you know, the white races.
So we didn't have time to savor things, the march or anything else.
It was a big event and also when as young people you don't hold on to things there are some more living to do right after that.
So that was what I remembered most.
But I remember the contradiction in my mind.
There's always people there.
And then we had now had a funeral of the most vulnerable people of all.
And they hadn't killed children before.
And that was another big thing that stuck out of my mind.
I remember writing a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, I'm sorry, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, the first being very upset about a child being killed.
Because we so identified with him.
Yeah. He was our age.
And right.
And in the throws of out of adolescent, adolescence, and here's a boy and the feeling was if they
could do that to him, they could kill my brothers.
I never thought that they would kill me, but I always felt they would kill me.
I felt they would kill my brothers.
Very deeply.
I remember I don't need to work to drink.
Remember that summer in matches when you were ill so frequently I understand because of
the pressure on them.
Yes, the stress.
I would go to sleep at night or not expecting to wake up.
Yes, and it was unusual because I've never seen a telephone that would ring in your hand
and it's off the hook.
And literally holding the phone, take the phone off the hook, the receiver and it's still
ringing because people in the south go to bed very early and the phone would start ringing
probably between 6'3rd and 7th and they would leave their phones off the hook so we had
no contact with the outside world and we would live right beside an alley.
So we never knew whether or not we were going to wake up and I developed stomach problems
from eating, it was pure stress, pure stress, but it made me more determined.
So determined one time that I went to Mr. Charles Evers had guns maybe close to 80 people arrested
and they would take an apartment in a tentry and I never followed him because I didn't
think that he was respected.
I didn't respect him.
So we were trying to get the bond signed.
You needed two signatures, the chief of police and you needed a property owner.
And so I got so frustrated because we were in a delta, we had to travel from Nat just
which is in the far south to the Mississippi Delta which is probably 200 miles to get people
out.
I asked one of the police officers where is the chief of police and he said he's at the
holiday in.
So I got a cab and went to the holiday in which was segregated and stood and had him
paid.
I was at the cashier's desk and had him paid standing in the middle of the floor.
I was that frustrated and that angry.
And so he never responded.
I don't know what he would have done if he had confronted me.
I don't know.
But that was the height of level of frustration that one would get to.
I got in the cab and went back to the house.
And another time I remember getting very frustrated was the next day after it was killed.
We went to the Masonic Temple.
Dave Dennis from CORE, his wife, Maddie Bivens, who was our cousin and myself went to the
Masonic Temple.
And there were two white police officers sitting on motorcycles and I ran up to the MSS
to scream him.
Where were you last night?
Why are you here now?
Shoot, shoot, shoot.
In the back like you did in Maddie Gabbard.
Just screaming.
Just enraged.
Enraged.
I had the amount of rage I can't even begin to describe.
And it was anger, frustration, hurt, pain, all everything you could think of.
And they sat there with their heads bowed.
And only recently have I begun to think that they practiced non-violence with me because
they never responded.
They think they were upset about the killing.
They never responded.
They could have turned around and shot me.
I know, but do you think they made it possible?
The insight is beginning to come to me as I get old and think that they looked sorrowful
themselves.
They had their heads down.
They never glared at me.
They never looked at me.
They never made any towards me gestures.
They just sat there.
And I was really enraged.
And it only came to me recently that they were using the same tactics, non-violence tactics,
passive resistance, with me that we used this in.
They probably felt bad about it.
Well, I might have struck that little core of the men into the man.
Well, as you keep living as mother, you say the more you live, the longer you live, the
more you learn.
And this is coming to me.
These revelations are coming to me that that was what was practiced.
Because I've been told recently that a lot of whites in the South and in Jackson, in
particular, did not care for that.
Well, I went to both trials and up for mega.
And the first trial was all right.
Although I had to kick some white men's feet because they put their feet up on the bench
and wouldn't let me sit down and I kick the foot and told them moving, then sat down.
That's the type of temper I had.
The judge told me to sit in and where they wanted to prevent it.
So the next trial, when the government came in, they made that goal up to the balcony with
a cane behind my head, the sheriff, a big thick cane.
And the mist trial happened so quickly until we didn't know we had gotten caught.
And only divine intervention happened at that particular time because we were caught
between the courthouse and the police station and the black street, the Far East street was
quite a distance.
And we were trying to figure out how are we going to get away from this mob.
And who would drive up at one Jess and Morris?
He said, do you all need a ride?
And we hopped in that Volkswagen bus and took off.
These are the kind of things that happen.
And that's why we are alive because there was a greater power than us that was looking
after all of us.
I said my serendipity.
But I remember seeing Ross Barnett walk into the trial of meckers, killers.
And I just, he went over and shook the hand.
And he was no different.
He was indistinguishable from the other clan supporters sitting there.
And I said, my God, there's.
Another time during that, we were going to go to Barnett's inauguration.
Why are you on that meckers trial each day when Beckwood would come in.
The clan would stand up and give him a standing ovation and a float and a float.
And he would bow.
Yeah, I mean, he was, and it was like some famous long-starred.
And the district attorney said, choosing a jury, Medgev was a nigger.
He lived over a nigger town.
I didn't agree with what he did.
And I know you don't either.
But it's my job to uphold the law.
Do you think it's wrong for a white man to kill a nigger?
And that's the way the jury was selected.
That's what Will and Wallace said.
Yes.
Yeah.
Did the D.A.
That's Paul from the district.
More right.
Just like, I don't mean to.
Of course.
I'm interested in this because it's one of so many indications of how extreme distress
and pressure was even on young and very energetic, as you said, all the young people.
I've read that you even were physically ill so many nights in matches because of the
It was a stomach.
And also eating greasy foods, the fried food.
We ate it.
What was called a White House restaurant that was owned by some sisters who were independent,
lots of land.
And every time I would eat the food would come up, fried chicken.
And now to this day I've watched my diet, I can't eat fried foods.
And this is hereditary I would have made.
I used to worry about her because I was often the safety of graduate school.
And I was, I lived with so much guilt, just tremendous guilt.
And I was worried my sister was still back in the South, but not only in the South, but
in the natures, she had the most notorious reputation for it being a dangerous place.
And we kept in touch by phone and I started working on her telling her it was time for her
to leave to come to get away.
And eventually she did.
She moved to St. Louis with me.
But.
You don't feel the because you had to be a nurse.
Because I left because I left and went to graduate school.
I felt that I wouldn't have changed anything.
But so living with guilt.
But at the same time feeling that you did what was best for you, it was the worst combination
in the world.
I didn't see it that way.
But I did.
I saw what I was doing is something that I had to do that I had to make some changes.
And the line was drawn in the scene.
And I had to cross the line and I had to go for it because I did not want to live under
the condition that had come before me.
And I didn't want to leave the conditions that way.
So it's a passion with me.
I think all of us felt that what drove us was that we felt the one that we were doing
the right thing.
We never questioned whether or not the cause was not a just one.
That was a foreground conclusion.
But I think my sister endured a lot more dangerous situations by far than I did.
But at the same time, I mean I was in enough dangerous situations.
But I always felt that I was always scared.
And I didn't want to be around people in the movement who.
But so I'm not scared, you know.
Because especially if they were northerners.
Because they could get you killed very easily because they didn't have respect for the
local traditions.
And because we sawderners knew what those conditions were.
We could decode them a lot quicker and easier, more easily than the northerners.
A lot of times they acted out of ignorance.
But because my roommate Joan Trump, I seen you a year or two glue, for example, used
to.
I don't care about these people, they're not going to do anything to me.
And I said, well, you're not going to get me killed.
I used to carry around a black scarf in my pocket.
And when we were driving back to Tugulu College at night, on this long stretch of road called
Hanging Mouth Road, there were no lights.
And Tugulu was eight miles from downtown Jackson.
So we had a, I used to put her on the floor.
And if she were going on the floor, I said we got to put this scarf on because your
long blonde hair is not going to get me killed.
And because you know, people will just shot at us, even if they just know we movement
workers.
And we were, there were no whites in the car.
But I came to understand, I guess, as I got older, that fear doesn't mean inaction.
I mean, courage was the ability to act or to prevail in spite of one's fear.
Because you could easily be paralyzed by your fear.
And if you, you know, my mind was constantly working.
I was sitting there, I remember once, Lawrence Giyat told me in a snake meeting, he said,
joy, if we listen to you, you know, you take everything to a logical conclusion.
We would do anything.
That's what I didn't mean it that way.
I was just trying to point, you know, because my mind is always working on this hand, on
that hand, that out of these, this is what would happen on one side of it, this would
happen on another.
That's what I didn't mean not to do it.
I was just thinking about what could happen.
Could I take you back for just a minute to a very specific material service, answer
question?
Could you describe the home you grew up in, in the home or should I say?
The what?
The home.
Maybe the, what it looked like, just like in the very environment.
Our home, our, our every home.
It was, we had three bedrooms, living room, dining room, kitchen.
Those were the covering on the house.
The house.
Brown, brown, brown.
Brown, we call it brickside here.
It was like, it rolled up and you would pull it out and it was, it looked sort of like
in the kitchen room.
We had a front porch.
We had, it was on one lot.
And we had, our younger brothers always had animals, usually there were rabbits or dogs.
They always had animals.
And we lived in a giant, just in the community.
Justin Back of us was great aunt and uncle.
And then to the right of them was our grandparents.
And so it was a modified compound that we lived in.
And there were no fences so we could go across the backyard and we're in a grand uncle,
an uncle arch in his wife, Spedis, Icy, and Icy's house.
And next door to them was Miss, I didn't miss the bill.
No, mostly.
No, that was later.
Later, later.
Yeah.
Grandparents, my stepfathers, mother and father, Bill and Ida Paraman.
And then other people on the street and back of us were neighbors.
Miss Katie, Mr. Joe, her husband, Mr. Grady, Mr. Grady and Miss, what's this greatest?
Miss, I think it's wife name.
Gosh, I forget.
But we, they were all part of this extended nuclear family and community.
And everyone interacted with you as though they were kind of family, the Quazai family.
But there are close by where our mothers, brothers and sisters who lived in the broader community.
And there were plenty of them.
A lot.
But down the street from us was a, I was a prostitution.
And that was the closest street.
Mr. Joe McCarthy had a steel whiskey steel and he made bootleg liquor.
Right.
And every month they share, they would come.
Like one eye, a finch in his black pack of car.
He would go up one side of the street with his hands stuck out.
Right.
And come down the other side with his hands stuck out.
One night, we had a lot of excitement.
Mr. McCarthy's house.
He had gotten, there was this, these big tractor trailer trucks would bring in what we call
steel liquor.
He stopped bootleg.
He stopped making a corn whiskey.
And he started selling what we call steel liquor.
And one Friday evening, we saw these National Guard trucks coming down.
And they went down and they found this liquor.
And then they started Miss Bambles across the street.
She had integrated prostitutes.
They broke the, we had flat machines.
White flat machines.
And then worked their way down Mr. Joe McCarthy's and broke liquor all night long.
Yeah.
There was a big rock and they took, opened these crates of liquor and they just break
them against it.
And you could smell liquor all over.
And they said the next morning, Mr. Joe, we could hear him of sifting the liquor because
the glass, he was sifting the liquor and trying to treat him.
He owned a lot of land.
He was in a wooded area.
So the community that we grew up in, if you ever camp Shelby, well, camp Shelby used
our community as an outpost.
Recreational outlet for the Black soldiers.
And so as a result, we had not a lot of care.
And so anything could go.
I mean, the police allowed the juke Johnson so on because they said ostensibly because the
soldiers were nearby and they would come to the high.
Not only the head of the Innsbruck Club and the club desire, the two night clubs.
And that's where all of the entertainers on the Chippewen circuit come through.
Plus we didn't need a far from New Orleans.
It's not.
And the Gulf Coast, you know, the Luxe and Gulf port.
So it was, head of the spirit was different than the Delta.
Southern part of the state was less overtly repressive day to day than the northern part.
And I'm hearing now that our schools were pretty good in head of spirit, farce county.
I know we had good teachers and so on, but, but, apparently they ranked, the farce
county schools ranked higher than they did in other places.
So I've been told.
But we, we lived on, there was a dirt road, no paved streets at the time.
And our address was Route 6, 6-9.
There was a post office on the corner.
One block from us was the school, the post office, and the school store.
He started out at, you know, one corner in this room would have been his little, little
grocery store.
And now his sons who are, you know, have stores all over the southeast, their Hudson
salvage stores.
Multimillionaires.
Yeah.
But, and that was what we called the crossing.
It was called Palmas Crossing.
That was the crossing.
Now the, the central railroad ran just across there.
And we, that city of New Orleans train came through.
And the, Miss Katie, our neighbors, brother used to throw the Chicago Defender out to us
as he passed by.
And sometimes some of the other, uh, uh, moving toward us would throw papers and magazines
out.
The description is so rich and good.
And I forget me for moving.
You should do a movie on this, on this, sort of insulated.
We talked about more with that, with Bernie's, the same stuff if you hear him.
Yeah.
You can go back and listen to it.
Let me ask you that.
Just one quick question.
Did you know you say that the, that the broth was in a break?
Yeah.
There was a black, a white prostitute living there.
And, uh, the, and the clients were, were black men.
Um, the sheriff, Miss Bamba, who just lived across the street from us and had shed a little
nightclub, a little juke joint there.
And she, and her house was there.
And every Monday afternoon when the sheriff, one of the fence came by, I guess we shouldn't
use his name because, uh, uh, uh, reserved rights for rights.
I mean, one of the best, uh, this is name.
No, but legally we should probably let them worry about the legal part.
But what happened is that the, the sheriff, Miss Bamba would go out and sit in the car
with sheriff.
She was going with him, dating him.
And he, they would sit there and then eventually they went inside and you say, see, you'll
take it on Monday out of her broth and had it on him money.
And I was a little budding sociologist, even back then, as a little child.
I was always curious about all these things taking place.
And then she, but get, she and he got out of the car and went in, in her house.
And I just assumed when my young man, that he was, they were having intimate relations.
He'd come out an hour or so later.
And what I wanted back then was, why does she have to pay him money and then have sex
with him?
I couldn't understand that as a little young child.
I mean, it was 10, 12 years old.
You had mentioned earlier, not just a few words about your mother, but how do your mother
know straight some of the ways your mother helped you understand how to navigate this world
as a lot of girls, coming up in a climate as a girl?
She said, go to school, get an education because no one was taking from you.
No one taken from you.
No one take care of yourself.
No one depend on you and the man to take care of you.
And see, I mother had been divorced from my father when I was an infant.
And she had for a while she had been a single parent to us.
And that had a deep impression on her.
She subsequently remarried.
Her stepfather had six children by him.
But she always told her girls, all of her girls, to learn to take care of yourselves.
And which is served as well.
Yeah, because we became very independent, very early.
What mother also taught us was to, we observed the way she navigated.
If a man insurance collector came by the house, they never came in our house.
She met the method on the front porch.
She didn't let them in the house.
And they didn't make passes at her.
There was a certain sense of pride and no nonsense behavior that she never let a
guard down with them, not at all.
And she treated them kept them at distance.
She did not cow-towel.
She did not let them allow them to make her feel that they were superior ever.
So going back, but that's the way she grew up.
Right.
She grew up, my assistant can talk about the family genealogy.
But for generations before, my mother's was the fourth generation in hours and fifth.
But five generations removed.
I mean, they were descendants of a Creek Indian woman, Mary, and a white man named Ben.
And he started genealogy research.
But at one point, they told us they passed on a lot of folklore about him.
And he said that he would not see his blood spilled across.
No, he didn't.
He did not enslave his children because he did not want his blood spilled across.
All over the world.
And so, and he was from Rockingham, North Carolina.
And so they grew up with a strong sense of grandpa Ben said that we're as good as anybody.
So that was passed on to each generation.
It was almost like school.
You heard these, we heard these stories from our uncles and aunts.
And there's such a sense of pride in who we are.
Plus, they always call themselves close.
And these communities, everybody was related.
And whether they were black or white.
And not formally, but informally everybody was related one way or the other.
And that's it.
You've been to the south.
I'm sure you've seen it.
And that's the way.
But they also had a very strong sense of independence and pride of self.
They, our uncles, most of the most part of their lives, didn't work for other people.
They were entrepreneurs.
They were taught not to work for other people.
Right.
Our grandfather worked for you, self.
And so they didn't put themselves in a lot of environments where they had white bosses.
For example, one uncle, Uncle Joe used to repair electronic things.
And one day he went to this white man's houseman, told him to come and fix his TV.
And he said he saw the screen was all broken.
And he said, well, what happened here?
The man told him, well, I saw this nigga on TV last night kissing this white woman and
I shot him.
And we just all laughed at my uncle.
And she said, you know, that's crazy.
You want me to fix it.
So there's nothing I can do with your TV.
And he turned and walked away.
And you can see my uncle had good sense with this man.
They were looking at a lot of white people who were like inferior to them in a way.
That's the way they looked at them.
And they didn't allow anyone to beat up on them, a mystery thing, even when they worked
for whites.
They used to tell us these stories about how they got in a fight with this person.
We beat him up or whatever.
And they were white.
And I just sit there mumbling, oh, that's fantastic.
You know, because it was just the opposite image that you had of the downtrodden negro.
They just weren't like that.
And so that was the model we got.
And we felt that when we joined the movement, we were doing what they prepared us to do.
And they were all very proud of it.
They were all unique because in that just, it was the prevailing culture.
And I think it's about the shift of teenagers into movement activity.
And especially after 1960, before we started today, Dr. Lamy were talking about just that
rush feeling, so much excitement and whole Oscar events.
I'm already quite surprised to talk about that.
The movement was the most exciting thing that one could engage in.
I often say that, in fact, I coined the term the Emmett Till generation.
I say that there was no more exciting time to have been born at the time and the place
and to the parents that movement, young movement people were born to.
It was through an accident of history that we were at post-war generation in the South.
At the time, we had the parents who taught us stand up for yourself.
That all of that thing, I mean, you're talking about synchronicity and serendipity.
All those things fell into place for a small group of young people.
And that was our generation.
We were post-war kids.
Some of our parents had gone, fathers had gone abroad to fight for freedom that came
back and they were so disappointed.
We were that of the era, they had been in the North as suburbanization of America, you
know, where the white kids, fathers were getting the jobs and they had the economics to expansion
and the material goods.
And we saw that we weren't getting those.
We were that generation that had been brought up with a fire and brimstone of believing
that they were old testament prophets on justice and, you know, just a strong sense of right
and wrong.
It was the morality of our times.
We believed that it was, according to the Bible, it was wrong to segregate people and
to treat one group of people better than the other.
We grew up with the liturgy of the Baptist Church that we translated to the Civil Rights
Movement with the songs and the preaching and the testifying all that took place in those
mass meetings.
All of these were factors and we were, of that generation where most important of all
was that all of us were imbued with the sense by our parents and aunts and uncles and
our neighbors who said that you are the generation that will do better and your generation will
change things.
I remember so clearly Uncle Archive who was in World War I went to France and he always
told us your generation is going to change things.
And so there was these expectations of us and I think we fulfilled them but I don't believe
those.
It was through, obviously it was not a matter of a king standing up in Montgomery and people
saying well you're right, it was, for us it was almost like you had to do it.
It was a matter of time.
The time had come and they expected so much of us.
Our teachers used to tell us.
These were the first, sometimes the first generation to go to college too.
That was critical.
They said they got a good education because no one can take that from you and I think
often my mother used to say that all the time.
But she grew up with her time when people took their labor from them.
They took everything from them and gave them little compensation for anything.
Our stepfather made $30 or $35 a week as a skilled mechanic, diesel engine mechanic.
His employee used to send him to New Orleans to his training courses.
And he retired on Social Security whereas the white men working alongside him had pensions.
They understood the injustices and while they may have felt they couldn't do anything about
they.
There was this spirit of rising expectations that we would do it.
We had so many mentors.
I remember one of our mentors was an herbalist.
We called him Dr. McLeod and he called him Cuz he was a cousin of our aunt.
He used to come and sit on the porch and talk to mother.
He was a member of the local Hesseburg branch in WCT.
He subscribed to the Pittsburgh Courier and Chicago defender, Jet and Ebene magazine.
He read so he would bring us books.
He brought us every week.
He brought us these publications.
And that was on the outside reading material that we got.
Because everything was censored.
Everything.
The radio.
There was one TV station in Hesseburg.
I remember when it came.
Arraped and they would call you Niggas on screen.
And we, that outside information just fueled our curiosity and fated and made us
want to see the world and do things differently.
It gave us the window into how the outside lived.
I mean, we saw that kids were going to college in Chicago and in Pittsburgh and all over
the North.
And it allowed us to see how other people were actually living.
And that could be ours as well.
But first we had to get rid of this little mat of segregation.
Discrimination.
Your first semester, or first year at the Jackson State would be a very busy one.
Yes.
No, it was a direction in terms of your culture.
Right.
See, we met Mega.
Well, I'll talk about that.
We met Mega Evans in high school when he came to Hesseburg to set up a, a, and in
WCV youth chapter.
He came down, but Clack and Arden, Vernon Damer, were the two people behind really.
The old Hesseburg, and WCV chapter did, but those two were the motivating factors behind
our chapter.
And the pianist, Vernon Damer's sister, played a piano in our church.
Her name was Hallean Beer.
She was my best friend.
She would, mother would let us go to NWCP meetings in Jackson with her and Mr. Damer.
And since she was in the church, there was nothing.
The mother trusted her.
You know, so, and our ears were wide open and taking it all in.
Clack and Arden, they drove up to Jackson and they took us with them.
And Clack and Arden, you're also interested in Negro rights.
So we called it.
Clack and Arden was our youth chapter advisor.
And, but the tragic thing was that we were so young when he was jailed and we knew that
it wasn't right.
The first time he went on campus and they said, they found moonshine in his car.
We were looking at it from a distance.
We knew him.
We didn't think that he would ever do anything like that, but it was so far away from him.
And when he was incarcerated, he stayed in jail in Hesseburg over a year.
And we could go downtown and walk past the jail.
And you wouldn't go up there.
But you didn't dare try to even go.
And we didn't even know how to negotiate going in.
No, there was no movement of any sort.
It was all too feel to into.
But later learned there was an underground movement.
But these were all adults.
We were kids.
The other thing you have to think about here is that look at this from the perspective of
14, 15-year-olds who know these things are not right and who would just love to someday
figure out how to make everything right.
But being also being very powerless, I will never forget how during our respond to Emmett
Till's lynching.
We used to go to the Hudson store every day at 4, 15, 4, 15, 4, 20.
That was when we had the city bus ran, went through to from downtown Hesseburg out to
Palmest Crossing.
And they brought the Hesseburg American on that bus at 4, 15, 4, 20.
And we ran up there with the damn every day and bought out a copy of the newspaper.
And I remember I used to clip out, clip the paper about Emmett Till's lynching and talk
about feeling powerless and frightened but also just like this is awful.
But that was my realization that if these men are guilty, why aren't they being punished?
Right.
And Dora wanted to be a lawyer then.
That's what a light bulb went off.
Why aren't they being punished?
And that's when I went on my quest to try and understand the whole legal system and equal
rights and justice under the law.
Dora used to have, let me finish, to talk about the Constitution.
And I went to my social studies teacher, Mr. Clark, and asked him, what does it, 13, 14,
15 amendments mean?
He said, this is something to do with the Constitution.
I went and found a copy of the Constitution and memorized these articles.
The America's Creed, the pre-eminent to the Constitution, all of this.
I'm sorry to repeat these all the time.
From my own empowerment.
And that was something that I felt that I could do for myself and maybe rule it off on
somebody else.
But that's how powerless I felt.
And these men are guilty.
And I hope they don't come down here and get me.
And I hope anybody else.
And it was Mississippi, was the closed society.
But it's a vulnerability.
It's a vulnerability.
I think cannot be overemphasized.
And we had two colleges there, Cary College and Southern.
And Southern was so racist, and what Clark can all try to enroll, they built a special
dorm for the students from Latin America.
And they had a lot of South American students too.
They stayed in a separate dorm.
They built it for them.
They built one recently for the Native Americans to live in on the same college.
Right now, yes.
I'm not going to speak.
So when we would go downtown, we would hear them speaking in this foreign tongue, but
we didn't understand what they were saying.
But it was a very curious kind of thing because we didn't see anybody but the people around
us.
And when we, Joe, and I would hear this, and we want to know who are these people, where
they come from, what are they saying?
And was just wanting to know more.
It's curious.
It just wanted to know more.
Wanted to know what was beyond.
We would go to New Orleans, occasionally, to the Gulf Coast, but not therefore out of
that little circle, the church, school, and home, and family.
And with friends.
But we also...
Sure, sure.
I just want to say, we would take the case of Clacknown as one that's perfectly illustrated
the way the White Authority would chop up some charge just to take someone out of the
landscape where he's going to work with Black Youth and so on.
Right.
And we did not know anything about his background.
And the University of Chicago was far into us.
We did know he was, in quote, smart.
Yeah.
We knew he was smart.
But later on we found out he was touring one of the Jewish kids there in Hattiesburg,
who was found on the big store, the department store.
And so, but he was very kind and very quiet, he's going.
And Medgev was the same way.
Now, we were teenagers and they took the tent with us.
We were young with us.
And this is the one thing about SNCC that I still marvel over and still think about.
At my age, would I follow a 19-year-old kid somewhere?
Right.
And that was the way we were presenting ourselves to the...
People in the community, the community organization.
And I think the reason a lot of these people took us seriously, most of them took us seriously,
was because we took ourselves seriously.
And because we weren't asking them to do something that we weren't already doing.
Well, we had a message also that was a message.
They resonated with that.
A message that they had been waiting to hear.
Right.
And the Christian bothers in a little child should lead them.
And I think that that was part of the whole thing too.
But looking back at it and thinking they had lived hard lives.
It worked very hard.
Right.
And to get people to leave their jobs, waitress in a cafe, house in the tent,
maize and sharecroppers, to go to the courthouse in Indian oil and Mississippi where Miss Fannie
Lou Hamer went.
In August of 1962, to get a busload of people to go and risk their lives and their jobs
and everything else to go there and stay all day long.
It's something that I marvel at right now.
Wondering how did it happen?
Where did they get that?
But they were ready for it.
The time was right.
This is 1962.
So we talk about Miss Rosa Parks.
And while we were sitting here talking, Emmett Till's death resonated because it was so publicized.
I heard a little about Miss Rosa Parks.
But there was not much information.
All we knew was that Black people were not riding the buses.
And that was about it.
But when Emmett Till's picture was shown, that was what blew the iconic photograph.
That was the image for our generation to galvanize our generation.
And all of us saw it.
We saw it on the cover of Jet Magazine.
And recently, I was watching, two weeks ago, I was watching TV one.
And they had this documentary on, I can't call this name right now, but on Emmett Till.
And Mrs. Mowley was talking, Emmett Till's mother was talking.
And she was describing how he looked when she went to the funeral.
They wanted to bury him right then and there without opening the casket.
And she went on, she said, no, I don't have time to faint.
I don't have time to do this, crying all this.
So she described each part of his body.
And all of a sudden, I told my daughter, I'm going to sleep.
And this was three weeks ago.
I could not at this age let that into my psyche.
I just went straight to sleep and slept maybe two hours.
And then I woke up.
I just thought everyone I knew and said, can not see it.
Everyone I knew and snickered.
Every black sub in a fashure had seen that photograph.
And it was like the clarion call for action.
And that when we got older, we were going to avenge his death.
I mean, I can remember feeling that so strongly.
I remember clipping those Hattiesburg Americans.
Each time there was an article about Emmett Till case in the trial.
And I kept a scrapbook.
I wish I had kept it years.
I remember one day taking it up to my play mama's house.
We had these teenage girls who would be your play mama.
They were like, nice to you and so on.
Like a young sister and man was Modell Stewart.
I remember one day taking this scrapbook to her house.
And I remember laying on the floor on that stomach, flipping through it, showing it to her.
I remember crying.
And feeling so terrible, evolvable, both the same time feeling that one day I'm going
to do something about this.
That was always the feeling that you could see these horrible things happening to people.
But one day, it's not going to be like this because I'm going to help to change it.
I'll never forget how the second lynching we experienced was that of McCharles Parker and
Poplarville, which is now 15 minutes from Hattiesburg back then.
It was probably 45 on the old roads.
And that was close to home.
I remember the international media came to Hattiesburg because Hattiesburg had a hotel.
It was the largest city in the hub city.
At least smaller towns nearby.
And during that, we go up to town as we call it.
Get on the bus and put it down.
We stood on the streets listening to these international reporters, foreign accents and
speaking in a foreign town.
And one time we were just pretending we were foreign too.
We were just sitting on the roof.
That was the roof.
Like making up words.
But I felt that they were our friends.
They were friends.
Our friends because they're here to tell the world about this.
And anytime I saw anyone that I felt was exposing what's going on, I felt a sense of empowerment.
But I remember also after McCharles Parker was lynched.
And as I said, it was so close to home that I remember my mother was starting pulling
the boys and my father in close.
I prayed to you better be brother next to me.
And I prayed to you home before dark.
I mean, it was like that natural, that protective instinct was to make sure that, because in
a way after I mentioned, we felt there was a lot of fallout from it.
It was not an isolated event.
It empowered the racist because they would stand out.
That chest stuck out and they'd talk about the niggers.
This is the niggers that they should have killed.
I wish I'd been there.
I would have done whatever to them.
I would have kicked them to a, I would have gotten me a shot on them.
And so these were catalytic agents for all the racism just to flourish out in the open.
And so it was that which you feared as much as the actual event that had occurred as well.
Because it was like the climate coming forth.
It's like Sarah Palin getting out here stirring up the tea party.
It's not just Palin, Michelle Bachman, but when they come around and they start talking
then all the other people who feel like them come out as well.
And that was the way I felt with these lynchings.
But the other side of it is the same perpetrators lived in the community and lived next door
exactly and everybody knew who they were.
But just the man who killed Mr. Vernon Damer.
He lived in the black community, had a little store, whatever in the community.
Everybody knew who he was and you couldn't do anything about it.
And one of the most, while I'm thinking about it, one of the most horrendous times that
I experienced was when we went to found Kofo in August of 1962 in Clarksdale, Mississippi.
This was my first time going to the Delta after Emmett Teales and all this had happened.
Bob Moses, Dave Dennis, Maddie Dennis, Koeladel.
I'm not sure quite a few of us went up there.
And Clarksdale had a curfew.
I didn't know that.
All blacks off the street at 12 midnight.
And when we got into the church, sure enough we got into the church, here comes a fire truck.
There's no fire here.
And so when the meeting was over, we were all subject to being arrested for passing the curfew.
And then we didn't know anything about it.
On our way trying to get to Jackson and it was dark in a thousand midnight in the Delta.
You've been up there, you don't see anything but the stars.
And so Dave Dennis was driving our car and we, the police got us before we got the Mount
Bayer, which is the old black town.
And so we stopped along this dark road and the police took him to his car and talked
about him.
Dave is a mixed heritage.
He discussed that with him.
Then he told me he was going to take him to jail.
And so Dave came and told us to follow him back to Clarksdale to the jail because he was
going to lock him up.
So we didn't know anything about the Delta and Lester McKinney, who was one of the freedom
riders from Nashville, was driving the car.
And so when we got to Clarksdale to the jail, the officer went and said, get the F out
of Clarksdale.
And so here we are riding around and around and around and around trying to find Amzen
Moore's house.
Amzen Moore was a World War I veteran who had worked on a lot of work in Mississippi with
the NWCP and 102.
And what was it?
It may have been two, but it would have been maybe two.
But anyway, he was known had a reputation for trying to work in the community and very
courageous man who got out of his way.
He hosted Bob Moses and so forth when Bob came down.
And so we were trying to find his house in Cleveland.
And we rode around and around and it was daylight, like six o'clock.
We had to go through Rueville and we had been told at Mowlum, one of the men who killed
Emmett Till was the night washman in Rueville.
And blacks were to be off the streets there at 10 o'clock at night.
And so when we got to Rueville, I said, Lester, don't go 20 and don't go under 20.
It was like you were paralyzed with fear.
And those are the conditions that people were living under and made it some still or I
don't know.
And then we said, we're going to do something about this right there in the Delta.
And that's how we decided that we were going to go and working the Delta, go and work with
the share crops and bring people like Miss Hamon to the courthouse to register.
That was where we stopped right there.
Exactly.
Let me go ahead and wait for a moment.
Did you do a lot of genealogy, research, delivery, Congress, or what were you looking for?
I have a few thoughts.
Okay.
On my questions and we will come to that.
Of course, yes.
It's obviously a very important issue.
Thank you.
That's a very, and I want to ask just one quick question on the way.
I'm thinking back of the work, how you were drawn in youth council and Emmett,
did you ever meet a no-root bond rocks bro?
I've never heard of it.
National, official and so she was also a serious contributor.
I just wondered if you knew in that context.
We met Ruben Hurley, who was the southeastern director of the NWCT.
Sure.
Let me have you.
I'm very interested in each of you have talked a little bit about your first experience
is going in to do local organizing, to the breaking that you mentioned in the Delta and
that context, really, 62.
The difference between us was that I always had one foot in the University of college and
one out and Dury dropped out of school.
Dury told me once, Joyce, I can't stay in school and no matter how people are suffering.
And I was always trying to figure out how I could do both.
So, when she left college, I was very upset, but at the same time I knew that
was her calling.
And I always did my movement work alongside my campus work.
I was more campus-based in a way.
But still spent time, you know, I didn't communicate organizing as well.
Well, the experience that I just described to you about going into Delta 1962,
this was also the time that James Meredith was enrolling in Ole Miss.
So, it was particularly horrendous time for the state of Mississippi.
And I made a decision.
I had left home that summer.
Joyce went to Chicago and to California with my uncle, Fontaine.
And I decided to go and work with Bob Moses in Jackson for my freedom as I told my mother
on my way out the door with my own surprise.
She said.
Wait a minute, let me tell my own story, please.
I said, Mother, well, shouldn't I?
I said, Mother, I packed a few little pieces and had a little small orange suitcase.
I said, Mother, I'm going to go to Jackson and work with Bob Moses to get my freedom
as I was going out the door to go downtown to catch the greyhound bus.
And Mother turned around to look.
But Mother had other children there.
And so, I went on downtown, got on the bus and went to Jackson and to the Freedom House on Rose Street.
And Mother turned to me and said, What's she saying?
She's going where?
And so, I was left to explain where she was going.
And you went to California that summer.
Well, I went to Chicago to work.
Then I went with them to California.
And so, that particular summer was the first summer that I had really dedicated my whole life
has been dedicated to the cause.
And from what I experienced that particular night on the roadside, there in the Delta,
and curfews which I had never heard of made me more determined to do something about the social change in that state
and throughout the United States of America.
And the other thing was that this energy that the Freedom Riders brought to the state of Mississippi.
So, these were young people.
We had been at Jackson State and James Meredith was one of our strategists at Jackson State.
And we had gone to demonstrate in behalf of the Tugulu 9 and tear gas.
But James Meredith was a great strategist, very clear-headed and level-headed.
But we had no idea he was going to Ole Miss, you know, he never meant to.
But then we were a torch it socially and otherwise at Jackson State.
We got expelled too.
And see, Meg Evans' office was across the street and every Wednesday we would go in and talk to him about our freedom,
which was abstract.
All we want to know was about our freedom.
We're going to get our freedom one day.
And we just had to ask him about what's going on with the movement, about Negro rights around Mississippi.
Because we'd ask him and he said, well, I went up to the Delta.
Or I went, one day he came on the campus and brought me some money because he had been in Hattestburg.
He was in a grocery store and he saw Met Moth.
I don't know how they got to know who each other was, but she gave him some money and he brought it on campus to kill me.
And we wanted to be a part of the Tugulu 9.
We asked him if we could join, he told us there was going to be a demonstration.
Can we join? Can we join?
First, he said, yeah, yeah, that would be good.
And then he said, on the other hand, no, because he started thinking about it.
He said, you would be expelled immediately because you can't sign out to go to the public library.
And he said, well, why don't you do something on the campus?
And Dury was president of the dorm council.
And she, well, always prayed before everything, events occurred.
And we decided that she'd call me to give a prayer.
And I wasn't by design.
No, I talked about the dark day of the meeting and I asked her to pray.
But why was it because I asked?
It wasn't by design.
Okay, I talked about the dark days ahead.
And the matron of the dorm was one from the darkest ages, from the caves and the hills and the names.
And she, even when it told the dean that a prayer had been prayed.
And we come from this small community, the Bible and this grocery store.
Everyone prayed before anything, just told them the south.
They wanted to know about the prayer.
And of course, we got very combative at that point.
How dare you question a prayer?
And we didn't realize that we were going to talk back and the leadership things started rising up.
And we defended ourselves.
Oh, no, you're not going to question us and question our prayer.
How dare you question my relationship with my god?
And so, so, so, precious started building.
And when we decided to march on behalf of the two blue students, the
Webateri gas and we had an early spring break.
Look, he called us to bring the president.
Jacob Reddick's called spring break early to calm things down.
When we came back a week later, Walter Williams, who's now a judge in Chicago, had been expelled.
He was the president of the student government.
He was expelled.
And it was toward the end of the semester that we were called in by the same dean, Oscar Rogers.
He died two weeks ago.
Oh, he did.
We talked to him and made peace with him last year.
You didn't really make peace with him.
You were still trying to ban on why he did what he did.
Well, I did.
I wanted to know.
I made peace with him, but he was sick.
I made peace with him.
No, it was not personal.
I was trying to find out.
Who?
How did, I mean, did the president tell him to expel us?
It was for me, it was a matter of getting to the bottom of it.
What, he wasn't, he didn't divulge any information.
No.
No, no.
But he, now this man had attended two little college, Harvard University and a
Divinja School.
You would think that he would have some liberal colleges about him, but he was enforcing the law.
Right.
You would think that about that, your explanation, the most likely explanation for your expulsion would be...
Expulsion?
He told me, Dean Rogers told me that, and you heard him say that we were the most intimidating people, and we mock, he saw the president walk past, and we mocked him.
I got to get him.
He had never felt so humiliated by the red light that's on over there.
Your questions, since we've been talking.
Hello.
The back after short break.
Let me, oh, let me just know for the record that Karen Bishop has joined us as well.
John's knees.
I wanted to ask, just for a quick description, the freedom house in Jackson is red on its character.
Oh.
It was a unique place, and having grown up in a large family, it was not uncomfortable for me.
The cast of characters, which included Lawrence Giyat, Cole Ladell, who was from Jackson, and the ten two of them also worked for Medge Evers,
would come and cook for us, because although I grew up in a large family, I didn't learn to cook.
I had to take care of the children, the younger children.
Blackhooked.
The house was, I think, initially rented by the Freedom Riders.
It was a big pole, break, pole, and Catherine Brooks, and Diane Nash, James Bevel.
That's the McKinney.
But it was a place that everybody could stand on one roof, and I was looking at some notes that I had come across recently.
About how we would question each other and talk about strategy, and so forth.
It was a learning experience, because I was learning, my first experience meeting the Freedom Riders was like,
Oh my God, what have you been?
What have you been?
It was a Masonic Temple upstairs by Megas office, and Tom Hayden, Charles McDue, Mary and Barry, John Lewis,
Dion Diamond, all these young people were there, and it's like, oh my God, I've been looking for you since I was 14 years old.
And so they stayed in state to do organizing, and that was the catalyst that we needed in order to continue to work that we had chosen us, all of us had envisioned there in Mississippi.
And it took them to come in to just break it open, and they had to support the local community, women united, a women power unlimited had organized for the Freedom Riders.
A lot of advocates there, for the Freedom Riders, from the local community.
So the network was vast, and once the Freedom Riders came in, that gave the infusion, the power, and every Friday we would go in to do the end of classes, to do community organizing and to learn.
And that was the first time I remember the Freedom Riders in depth, I remember that seeing them over there, but also remember them on campus.
We got to Tugulu, the Freedom Riders had come back for their hearing, and it was early September, and I saw all these people, whites, and blacks sitting out on the lawn, and just relaxing, and so on.
And I remember asking someone I think was roommate, who were those people out there, and she said, oh, those are the Freedom Riders, I said, what?
And it was extraordinary, because we had wanted to go on the Freedom Riders, and our father, and uncle told us we couldn't do it.
We had gone to Chicago for the summer to work, but we wanted to join the Freedom Riders, and the reason they told us we couldn't was because it was so dangerous.
And that was the last time we ever asked anyone if we could do anything, from then on we just went ahead and did it.
Someone told me that they saw a record where George Russell Moore had put me out of the court.
I attended a trial with one of Freedom Riders, and one of the police officers was telling so many lies, and I was sitting there looking, and the George kept looking at me, and then finally he said,
with a young lady in the black dress, get up and leave, and I got up and stuck and threw my head and went on out the door.
But it's recorded some way, because someone told me that they saw it, but it was one of the Freedom Riders trial.
If so transparent, the lies were so transparent until just couldn't help but sit in the marble, and I'm one who usually gives them a self-aware by looking.
Expression?
Expression, rather severe.
And someone called him a film set.
No, someone has written it.
I was in jail.
But George Cox, the Federal Fifth Circuit, was so evil. He referred to us as niggas in the courtroom.
And I had, when I went back to Jackson to the 50th Freedom Riders reunion last summer, I met a young black man who replaced George Cox.
It was the most amazing thing. I couldn't believe he said, I tell him, I said, when he was introduced at this dinner, and that he was on the fifth circuit, and I went up to him afterwards, and I said,
I was tried by George Cox, and he said, I replaced him.
As you got him, he was kidding.
This is quite injustice in my herd.
I couldn't believe it.
It was truly remarkable. 50 years later.
I'm so looking both to all the work that goes down to Mississippi, that you were right in the middle of, especially Miss Ladner, in voter registration, in the MFDP.
Maybe we can enter into that, and touch on that. Very, very important work.
Let me have you say a little bit about Victoria Graham House.
She's our cousin.
We remember her from the time we were little kids, because Melissa Remarkov had her number one. She was very beautiful.
And number two, she went away to college. We knew people who went to all corn colleges at Jackson State.
She went to Wilbur Forest, and we said, that's far away at. We want to go away to college.
She was made up of her.
She went away to college.
I remember we were little kids at the time, but I remember so well.
I remember also when she went to live in Germany, because she got married to Tony, and when she came home from Germany, it was another way of looking at her as a very exotic person, because she lived abroad.
And we were, in college, when she became active in the movement.
First, by working with SCLC's Citizenship Education Program, and then she joined SNCC.
And we were away a lot of the time when she was doing her work, but she gained stature as she got more and more involved.
She was always Victoria, our cousin, Vicki.
When she was number one, an independent entrepreneur.
She's so cosmetics and haphazard.
She was always open and engaging, very, very intelligent, and never put herself above the youth.
She was always on the level and would listen to what you had to see.
That was a common characteristic of all the people who older people.
When she came in, she was in Hattesburg.
A long time, Gia was in Hattesburg.
I chose not to work in Hattesburg because of my residency there.
But she joined up with Gia and some Frank Smith and some others.
And she would come to Jackson in her high heels shoes and her tight dresses.
She dressed well and a very skilled art, a very skilled art.
It's a really smart, very bright and magnetic personality.
When she died, it really pained me.
It still pains me when I go to meetings.
I look for her, help me always sit next to each other.
And it's something that is just part of me.
But she was a teacher and confidant.
She was proud of us too.
She knew that we were little kids who came out of Palmer's Crossing and made a way slowly into the world.
She had a sense of pride in her little cousins.
She was, and I know she was in fact, in Atlantic City.
Yes.
And then you can use her presence there as kind of an opt-in talk a little bit about Atlantic City and MFDP.
And that moment in the movements of the revolution.
And a little about how we got there too.
She took a lot of blue-sweetened tears to get there.
A lot of people were jailed, beaten, and getting there, the organizing.
A lot of work went into it.
And to take an integrated route to Atlantic City.
But that summer.
To the bottom of the city.
Yes, that summer bonding and so forth.
And also, Swarna Chain Goodman had been murdered.
And that was another...
We knew Mickie Swarna and James Chainner from the Mississippi Movement.
They were staff people, you know, who were always in Jackson at the staff meetings.
Mickie wore a little go-tie.
He and Rita had just come down from that January, I guess, from...
I know he had been at Brooklyn College.
Maybe she was as well.
They hadn't even gotten seasoned.
I mean, they were seasoned because it didn't take long to get seasoned.
Become a seasoned volunteer.
It was a baptism of fire.
As soon as you got there, you got thrown in feet first.
But I remember all the debates that we had about how to approach...
See, all of our projects were...
There were two types of projects.
One is that we were actually doing the strategic work of helping to get people registered to vote, to gain power.
And the other level was to take some of those same events, as well as create others.
That could be sort of pushed out to the national stage to bring attention to the injustices in the South in Mississippi.
Now, the, for example, I remember Freedom Day in January 1964, in Hattiesburg, was the precursor to Freedom Summer.
And the MFDP, you know, you can only organize for so long to get people registered to vote.
Before you bring attention to the fact that he's saying people not only can they not vote, but they can't be a part of the political party.
And so we started organizing...
We had to mark ballot. If I could vote, I would vote for Linda Baines.
And you had to go bare gold war.
Freedom ballot, in order as well.
When all over the... I know in matches we went all over Adams County with these.
And we had to take, have these as testimony to also attest to the fact that we weren't registered to vote.
And we documented everything.
And this was taken to the government as well.
In each area.
And then we had to precincts.
We organized the same way you would any political processes.
And then the district white.
And then the state white.
I think it was early August.
Yeah, then in line...
And then in Lyons, there's a picture of Freedom Day and Mr. Baker.
And the picture, Ella Baker, is given the credit for MFDP.
The concept of MFDP.
She was our leader.
We didn't bother leaders, but she was the world's great leader.
Because she taught us how to listen to each other, but she also taught us.
She respected us so much that she was standing along the side of the wall in meetings.
And we'd argue and argue and argue.
And then she would...
Someone would call for the question, you know.
And she would guide you with an unseen hand to eventually arrive at some kind of a consensus.
But I remember...
What importantly, she separated the students from the SCLC.
That's how SNCC came into being.
Now, I remember the statewide convention was held at the Masonic Temple.
This is a statewide Democrat, Mississippi Freedom Democratic Party convention.
And after the delegates were chosen, I remember riding up to Atlantic City in a convo of cars
with cleave sellers and Avon Holdonels.
And each person has snuck out a skill.
And I like to think of the drivers.
The very, very important skill that was used to drive as a driver, a SNCC driver, of the Sojourner Fleet of Cars.
Rubidaris Robinson named him the Sojourner Fleet, by the way.
And because you had to be able to drive in very dangerous places, you had to get in and out of places like Dora was describing earlier, being up in the Delta.
And you had to outrun the cops.
And we drove in a convo of cars up to Atlantic City.
But we stopped in Denmark, South Carolina, at cleave sellers' parents' home.
And we showered, changed, and his mother cooked great meal.
Then we went on the second leg of the trip, on up to Atlantic City.
And we had walkie talkies too.
So cars, we traveled in a fleet together.
So I think it was about three cars together.
I'll never forget that trip up there.
And then once we got there, I stayed at the Y.
I stayed in a little small hotel.
Yeah, that was the convention, the FNPs Hotel.
And we had the Burnout Station wagon on the boardwalk.
Right.
For the front.
The swarrow chain and good men.
It was a car that Mickey, Michael Swarrow, James Cheney and Andrew Goodman were driving when they were killed by a recent kill by the sheriff in deputy and local people in Phyllida,
and they burned it up after the car afterwards.
And the Chokto native found it in the swamps, in the woods there in the showroom county.
And we told that car up to Atlantic City, put it on the boardwalk, and different people stood there and explained what it was as people at the convention stopped.
And I remember being standing there and people wanted to know, what is that?
And then once you told them, this is what the three freedom routers,
three civil rights workers were in, driving when they were killed, then it just took on, I mean, it was this symbolic manifestation of just the most other type of fear and they could understand.
See, one thing we understood in the movement, and I'm not sure how, as young as we were, how we understood, came to understand it, but we showed people what it was like as much as possible.
It was a tactile thing, like lots of photographs, a lot of booklets we put together, freedom ballots, literacy books, teaching plantation workers, literacy, you might have a sentence that one sack of cotton weighs 80 pounds, another way is whatever.
And total is 160 pounds, but we used things from the environment.
And so taking that car to the boardwalk in Atlantic City, for everyone to see that this is what the three civil rights workers were driving.
And then you know you've heard that they were murdered, bodies were found, and they burned this car like this, and people were just, wow, we could understand why this Mississippi segregated delegation shouldn't be seated.
And I had seen them at Miami University in Oxfowl, Ohio, as they were leaving to return to Mississippi because they had, we'd gotten this call that the church had burned and making up a course with, and James were, what, immediately returned.
And, and they jumped in the car, he was a volunteer, he had not been to Mississippi before, so we went out to the car and told them together.
And word came back that they had not been heard from through the Watt's land, and I remember in the meeting volunteers were running around, you know, full of energy.
And then we said, this is very serious, very serious.
And Herbert Randall captured a picture of me, he may have seen it with my arm out wearing a white blouse.
And he explained me what happened was that I was talking and explained the seriousness of what was going on that we knew they were dead.
And then I took it outside and continued to talk. And then he captured a picture of me sitting there with my head about, we all knew they were dead because you had so many hours or minutes to check in.
Right. Once you didn't check in, then we started calling.
But we blame the federal government for not intervening earlier, and they could have been saved because I heard recently that some of the cooks who worked at the jail had told people in the community that they had the word out there in the jail.
And they didn't. And that was something that we had to live with and really, really, really disturbed us.
So what I often have thought about over the years is we were so young to have been exposed to so much death and so much violence.
And some people, what we call our walking wounded, they didn't survive it intact. I mean, the movement destroyed them.
I won't say the movement destroyed them, but they were the casualties of the movement. And we don't talk about them enough.
But to be 18, 19, 20, if you were 25 and snick you were older, considered old.
But to be 18, 19, 20 years old and you're exposed to all this danger and all of this violence and all of this fear all the time.
It's a wonder that as many people survived as did. It's truly remarkable, I think.
When they came to Berk, attempted to blow our house up, our office up in the natures.
They blew up the wrong house according to the fire chief. I asked him who's house was that, who's ours.
And they had burned bomb through a cocktail and this cafe that belonged to an integrated couple according to the police chief. He had known them since he was a kid.
And he was a Jake Fishman and his black mistress. And so we, there were mob of people there.
We got word that our office had been blown up. So we ran over there. Every white person in the natures knew it was going to be blown up.
And we got there. They were standing all around like in an alley and we had to go through there and Mr. Archie Curtis, the funeral director, was there with his attendant.
So we felt that we had to go inside and get the names of the people who had signed up with us on the full by four cards.
And prior to that, John Doah had been sending two justice department officials down there.
Young white guys were sawing our shot. They let us see them. They said they weren't coming anymore because it was getting too dangerous.
We were coming to check on us every week to see if we were alive. And so they weren't coming back. And this is when the attempt was to blow up the office, but to make it long story short.
We went, Mr. Curtis said, I'll take you all in there to get those names and nobody's going to bother you. And so we went inside. We had turned the light on and come out.
We went through the model people and got in the car and drove back to Mr. George Medcalfe's boarding house.
And the phone rang all night until I told this woman, who kept calling, door you, MF, just that.
I said, you know what? Little Richie is coming to the town. I said, you like little Richie? Yes, I like little Richie.
I said, well, if you don't call anymore, I'll get you a ticket. You will, Dory. I said, yes. I promise you I'll get you a ticket.
I said, you don't need to worry. Thank you so much.
There was a lot of danger. I remember.
It's sanity. It's sanity. Right. It gets a frenzy.
I mean, it's psyche. The cash, WJ cash, wrote about in mind of the South, is so appropriate here.
I remember being in Greenwood in spring of 64.
It was in 63. 63. And the police, not the police, but I worked in the SNCC office all day that day.
And I was one who didn't mind doing office work.
And then that night, left office, almost midnight.
Went home, learned they'd blown up the office that night.
And the morning got up and found out about it, went in there and cleaned up all the files, got retrieved everything possible.
And I don't think, I mean, a satire in the momentary danger, but you say, oh, that's horrible.
But we did skip a beat. You know, the next day, we were out there again trying to get people to go down to the,
but going with people down to Greenwood, the Florida County Courthouse to register vote.
And these police dogs that chasing us and here come, along come someone, hollering.
Where is the pay phone? Where is the pay phone? And I said, I said, she's, I want to call the Justice Department.
And I stopped at Justice Department. I want to call the Justice Department.
I didn't know any black person who knew anyone in the Justice Department to call.
So I was taking a back. I found that more curious than the dogs chasing us.
So I turned around and turned out to be Marion Wright, who was at Yale Law School.
And she had spent some of her interning at the Justice Department, but she was there that spring break working with us at Greenwood Voter Registration Campaign.
And I told her about that years later and she said, and you know what, I was calling John Doerr and she said, you know what he told me?
I said, what, she said, calm down, calm down, tell me what happened.
I said, and then Mr. The Dogs chasing us, that was easy for him to say.
And one thing that I left out about the bond was that there was a local young lady from the National Black With Us.
She had a daceted tooth faint of fall out on the ground.
And what was I going to do with this? If you choose to faint here, I'm stepping over you.
We go in in the office and I'll leave you here. I don't know what happened to her.
But that was the, the man said, you don't, you didn't have time to do certain things.
No, and you didn't faint. But I had the amazing capacity that I didn't know I had. I've analyzed it many years later.
To be in the dangerous situations and separate myself from it almost, it was like almost being out of body.
Like the next morning I got up and went, cleaned up the files and didn't even really deal with what had just happened emotionally.
I just didn't deal with it.
So, relative we close to the end of the day.
Okay, sure. Why don't you ask what you said.
Let me just, I definitely want to ask a few things to make sure that we can actually hear your sense of a few things.
I must be close out here and I'll have time for any final comments for you as well.
But let me mention the, the, the, the, the, the, the terms used in kind of a form of a way to talk about the people who suffered from, from witnessing all this violence, the law being wounded.
Right. And I wonder if there are any things that more that you would like, I don't really like to talk about the legacy of that violence being so close to that much violence.
But personally, enduring it and witnessing it at close hand.
Well, and now this day that the term terrorism is used, it doesn't phase me because I've lived through all that.
I've lived through, I've seen that was terrible.
That was terrible.
And to churches, and to homes, more than I can count right now.
And being chased, I never, I didn't know how to drive at the time.
And I would always sit in the back seat of a car because for fear that whoever was driving, and another driver sitting in front seat, for fear that if a guy would come by and pick up truck with a rebel flag and a gun.
That the next person would take over wheel that Jimmy Travis was shot in the Mississippi in 1963.
So there are some things now that flash across my mind like PTSD at times.
And you don't realize until it surfaces.
But the violence part, when I didn't happen to, it doesn't affect me in the same way because I personally lived through it.
So I don't get all upset.
You've been so sensitized to this.
It's something that happened.
And I'm not condoning it, but it's something that you just sort of, sort of, is in your whole psyche.
I don't think I've dealt with a lot of things that happened.
I think I just sublimated a lot of stuff.
And I believe a lot of it went into my work.
I believe that I worked very, very hard because I loved working.
And I pushed myself, I was driven, just very driven in my work.
And I think that a lot of it came from not only being a very active, engaging mind that caused me to want to seek more knowledge and write books and do research and so on.
I did the administrative teacher and all those things.
But I think also it was to keep me, I didn't have to remember a lot of things either.
And I spent several years working in Level 1 Trauma Unit.
For me, it was like out of my experience, although working with certain death and all this kind of stuff, I was like prepared to work with it.
And although I said I never want to say that I've got used to the sight of blood, that means I'm no longer human.
But I was sort of desensitized to a lot of stuff that I saw tragedy.
I'll tell you that in spite of all that, my very worst moment in the entire movement came on the early that morning 6 a.m.
So morning, my mother called to say Mr. Dame was killed.
It was 6 to 6.
I'll never forget that I was in graduate school in my apartment.
And I just stood there and broke down and just started screaming and crying.
All those years of repressing so much, and what I couldn't understand, because I was always, I never reacted entirely emotional to things.
I was usually filtered through my mind first and I was like, I can't understand then, how he lived through the worst, the most fearful, terrible, time of the movement and then to die after all of the violence,
after the most violent period that I couldn't reconcile.
One more thing about Lennox City, we were assigned to work with, to lobby with different members of Freedom Democratic Party delegation.
And I was assigned with Mr. Mrs. Hartman Turnbull.
Mr. Turnbull, we always called his wife Mrs. Sweet's.
And we were to lobby the Oregon delegation with Edith Green, Congresswoman, Edith Green, and Senator Wayne Morris.
Now, I'll never forget going into the hotel, into the sweet, not a beautiful suite in this hotel, like a penthouse.
Edith Green was wearing a beautiful caftain.
And Mr. Turnbull presented the case of the FTP very clearly, and then Mrs. Turnbull was very quiet, she never said anything.
She was carrying a brown paper bag, she had a pistol in it.
I always thought that was just so fantastic. I thought that was a gas man.
I loved it. I loved it.
You know, their home had been blown up, and then he was accused of being the bum of his own home.
So she didn't trust these people in Lennox City.
She had a gun. I thought it was a, you know, when you're young, you just see the iron in all kinds of stuff.
I thought that was great.
Most people had guns.
A lot of people had guns, and they didn't say anything about it.
You just mentioned iron in it that there are, I don't know, that's iron in the white, but there are so many layers of complication to sort out an emulation of the question of your experience that came out of the geneological work,
which is that of course there's this whole contemporary white side of the family, so to speak.
Yeah, very interested in your, if you'd like to.
Well, it came from living in my mother's family, especially. I didn't live around my father's side because they all had a Mocha Chicago in California.
And my mother and her brothers were always different, meaning that they were malatos, Indians, or whatever.
And they would talk about their life and being wooled was a...
The Dippity was a man who called the Copeland Gang, and so they called them a squatter, yes.
Spotter, spot like you spot these crops.
So I was intrigued, and also was intrigued by my mother's family because they were different from most people in the community, the hair and coloration and so forth.
They looked Indian.
And after listening to Canadian broadcasts and one night in 1992, they were making them move in Jackson Freedom Song.
So they announced on the radio that the Canadian broadcasts and that the archives were open in Jackson, the Civil for Black People, 1992.
They had finished all the slave records and you could go in and use them.
So I took the opportunity to go and start doing the research. All of my mother's siblings were alive at the time.
They lived the 80s and 90s old. And I started collecting information.
And the more I got into it, it became like a disease, which is still there.
So to make a long story short, you know, when you're doing research, people are also doing research, the same kind of research.
And someone saw that I was researching the same great, great grandfather that this family was.
And so they were approached and said that you may want to know this or you may not want to know it.
One in Georgia was approached by a lady in Alabama who was doing her research.
She said, I want to know it and I have a assistant in England.
So of course we want to know. So I received a letter from England from London, England saying that we may have a great, great grandfather.
And I would like to communicate with you and send photographs, exchange photographs.
And that's how it happened. And we met in Mobile, Alabama.
And we met again in 1998. And we had two reunions. And we went to the family cemetery.
And my mother had grown up in Bowies, Mississippi Wayne County.
And to look at cemetery and also to eat.
And I spent a great deal of time going into cemeteries looking for a Benjamin F. Willard who was born in 1805 and rocking him North Carolina.
And we didn't find what we found Benjamin Willard, Jr. who was in the Confederate war.
And from the information that both sides get collected was that Benjamin Willard had around 11 children, no, 13.
And five, five, five, five, our great-great-grandmother, Mary, who was described as a black creek Indian.
But she probably lived in Seminole, come from that part. And they had both, they're both born in 1805.
And they both came from North Carolina to the Alabama, Mississippi territory together. And they lived together.
And the first child, Frank, were born 1825. And our great-grandfather was born, Jerry Willard was born in 1870, around 1869, 1870.
And he was a father of my grandfather, Joseph Collins Willard. And Joseph Collins will marry Martha Gates.
And our great-grandmother, and she, they'd be 11 children, and my mother was the fifth of 11. And her roots.
And mother died, mother born May 14, 1921, and she died on January 23, 1995.
Now my father's side is so-
He's got something. Stop.
I couldn't move it around.
I thought she said he had something.
Oh, he was.
Oh, yeah.
You'll forgive me for the question.
You're just interested in your thoughts about this experience of, if you'd like to share, I have another question too.
I can finish with if that's not really something we'll talk about this. This element, you know, the 90s of empowering this part of the band.
Is this the part of the band?
Oh, well, we knew it was the other time. It was never-
They were surprised. But our existence, we weren't surprised about this.
But my mother used to have relative come to visit me, because I had a root, so-
It was white.
Yeah, so there's no deal.
And my sister, Joseph, now probably only identified with black Latiners in the country.
Those who claim color.
So the resistance comes on the white side.
I mean, the white-well-
Woolers don't want a descendants of the Woolers can't find any other white Woolers.
And they make all kinds of excuses.
Well, they just melt in the Latiners of this large Creole family in Louisiana,
which includes Brett Fogg and Jimi Buffington.
And many of the Fogg's do have integrated reunions.
Jimi Buffington is from that land, and so forth.
But they decided early on that they would rather stay in the white race than the black race.
I don't have a question. We were right at the time. Sorry.
We don't have lots more times. I would enjoy being with you for that.
Are the parts of the civil rights narrative that you really think need attention to be re-crafted or adjusted?
Well, mad is mainly the schools of children to know the history, the history part,
because it takes, as I think, as an example, where you have a revisionist who do work
and throughout the whole curriculum of the country, not only in elementary, high school,
but college students don't know. So I think that that's my main concern.
Yeah. What were we needed for our conversation?
Yeah, my last.
Oh, okay.
Sorry. I'm sorry. I'm forgiving the abrupt end of our conversation.
Thank you so much. It's been a real privilege.
You're welcome.
It was really great.
You enjoyed it?
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.